[Music]
now we all met at carpool karaoke and
this is another part of the holiday I'm
leading into so you you know your
romance was budding was it love at first
sight actually I've heard from Jonathan
I want to know from Zoey we knew like
right Linda like we knew like oh it's
just a friend
yeah but we can't know how to come join
I wanted I didn't want there to be
pressure for the whole gaggle of people
with me yeah so that's why I that I
invited her for dinner and actually when
I was going to our first date I didn't
actually know if it was a day just know
I didn't know cuz though on our first
date actually Linda and I met during
Fashion Week at a fashion event and so
our first all I know I was there yes and
I thought that maybe you guys were there
like each other's know we were the
celebrity models in this like fashion
yeah just really like hey you guys were
there like the you were there when I
just remembered that we all got into a
car together the first night we met well
because that was the whole thing is back
there so you weren't looking for any you
were in your
you weren't single at that time and so
we're like but these are cool people and
so so I think I was actually the one
that even said we're driving yeah why
don't I give you guys a ride yeah and
then the funny thing is speaking of a
criminal mind cause yeah apparently I do
a lot of stuff that I remember getting
home that night and telling my sister
like I'm glad we're alive like why don't
we just take a ride from two strangers I
was like oh like you're so happy you're
alive because you had the bathroom that
too
this by the way is plastic Zowie eternal
optimist yeah
[Music]